um so in today's session we're going to
do a kind of quick overview of the
project drivers what kind of
drove us to create dapper reviewed the
key capabilities
that dapper has we're going to do a
short demo on a service composition
using dapper in a kind of event
processing application
i'm going to cover the project status
and roadmap on the end and
hopefully there's going to be about 10
15 minutes on the end to do a q a
so let's get going uh so before i want
to go into the actual overdubber i want
to review some of
the kind of things that drove us to
create uh
dapper and what it's trying to solve um
i think there's many different
uh reasons for that but i think they
boil down to three things i think
um too often developers nowadays
they're step one in writing any new
application they have to decide where
this
where this application is going to run
because moving that application later to
a different platform
will often require a complete rewrite
the other thing is that
these total or complete platforms do
help
and they kind of solve holistically a
lot of different problems but because
um uh you have to kind of buy in 100
into into
using them they tend to kind of evolve
slower
and over time kind of drift away from
what's considered to be a modern
architecture
and as a result in the third point um
the in the average company today
i've spent over the last year probably
talking to i don't know 30 40 different
companies out there and developers in
those companies
the um the average developer the gap
between what the
existing application looks like and what
it's considered to be
modern application in the community is
increasingly larger and larger and it's
not common to find companies that have i
don't know 1500 to 2000 applications
that they want to modernize but i want
to do it all in one
split move so these are kind of the
things that
set up the context for dapper and the
type of things that we would like to
solve for
uh for the developers so let's go into
the upper um
first of all just a short overview the
opera stands for distributed application
runtime
yes we've abbreviated three words into
four letters um
i know it was hard but we've done it in
a plain english dapper is really an
event-driven application it's
portable runtime that helps developers
build distributed applications
regardless when they run them whether
it's a bare metal cloud
edge devices and i mean actually edge
devices like raspberry pi or something
the the runtime is kind of independent
of that it's an open source project
it's hosted on github under mit license
and
it has a very open governance we just
recently tweeted uh the recently
wrote about it about a transition to
open governance
and the commitment to vendor neutral
foundation
for dapper throughout the presentation
you're going to see some qr codes they
have posted in here that will have
direct links to places where you can
actually learn more about the thing that
i'm talking at that given time
in this case it's a link to our blog
post that we just
that i just mentioned so that's kind of
what those qr scores stands for there
all right a little overview of kind of
where we are with dapper today
less than a year it was october 2019
when we announced the upper so
we've had 11 releases as of this am i'm
happy to say
and i think we've landed the 11th uh
release of dapper or 11 major release so
v1011
there's a decent number of image pools
that actually signals a real live usage
so this is not just
the kind of things that it's out there
and sitting but people using this in
real life
we have 70 plus different components
that cover pretty much
the entire cncf data and messaging
spectrum of
of the map that you often see and and
more about those components in a minute
and
there's a growing number of also
contributors which validates the sense
of broad community
and helps us kind of drive
the direction of the project as a
consensus of the
overall community and of course the all
important stars that
we all know are the critical to any open
source project
i'm being sarcastic here so what are
some of the kind of uh principles that
there are behind dapper so first of all
no limitations with regards to the
language or framework if if
uh if a new language come out comes up
tomorrow um
something like you know i don't know i
can't even venture to
think of what that would be we should be
able to run
if you can start it if as a process we
should be able to run it inside of
dapper
the other thing is that there is maximum
emphasis around reuse and of those
building blocks as we refer to them and
again more about those two but those are
a la carte
opt-in mechanisms that you can use to
kind of
bring in certain capabilities that are
common in modern distributed
applications
those when those building blocks are
when the available building blocks
don't meet your needs or where you want
to expand the functionality of that
building block
dapper provides a facility for you to
kind of
add an additional capability or expand
or change the implementation
which is very important if you want to
be able to kind of allow people to
scale and grow their application with
their demand
um at the core of dapper is also this
well documented eight set of apis that
are that provide a parity across
multiple protocols and runtimes so
grpc or http protocol doesn't matter the
the shape of the api the functionality
is is the same
even though the protocols are different
and it runs like i said before runs
great on kubernetes as well as any other
infrastructure where it can be like a
standalone process
we've done this on bare metals we've
done it on raspberry pis like i was
talking about
um data center customers data center
wherever you can get kubernetes for
example it will do and it's also
supporting multiple architecture so
intel arm macklin linux and windows
um you can get either the um
readily available version of dapper or
just compiled for those two
and and and the last thing is the doctor
really tries to meet the developers
where they are
the investment that you've done in
learning particular language java.net
python whatever that may be we want to
make sure that you feel at home
in in kind of natural idiomatic is just
a fancy term for
natural to you that should make you
effective
on day one there is no courses required
there is no certification
use it incrementally start small and
then build from there
so hopefully that will give you a good
background where dapper was going kind
of logically and we'll go deeper into
each one of those but logically
dapper uh at run time kind of exposes
those
apis like i was saying http and grpc
these apis give you access to the most
common
usage patterns that we've seen in
distributed applications
and we generalize them into something
that can be
consistent to you as a developer but yet
flexible underneath
so you can plug specific implementation
of that and we'll talk about those in a
second too
and we refer to those as building blocks
and you will hear me saying building
block building block throughout the
presentation
and uh when combined they will provide
like an open programming model that you
can
start today very small and then move
from environments change your mind and
apply these config through configuration
without rebuilding your application so
hopefully never again we hear about
somebody
uh needing to move 1500 application in
once we move to a new platform
so more on those building blocks going
deeper into there um
these blocks are uh they're independent
so they're not in there's no dependency
between each one of those blocks so we
let's go through those one by one
service to service invocation or it's
it's a basically a reverse proxy like
api for communication between multiple
services within your application so if
you're building microservices
you're building any number of different
services inside of
something that's considered to be an
application and for you to be able to
dynamically discover those services and
connect to them
that's where where dapper comes in the
other common thing that we see pretty
much is state management
think about durable key values object
store like s3 or gcs
that gives you this put get
verbs capabilities that allows you to
kind of query by
by state the shape of those apis
is pretty consistent yeah they have
different functional capabilities but
to large degree we can give you a very
consistent api to that
uh to managing your state in your
application
with regards to pops up this is all
about messaging within application there
is
um you know a different perspective on
what market market
micro services should be doing they
should be servicing to service
invocation directly
or they should be in synchronous through
pops up the upper provides you both of
those
so if you're looking for a messaging
between your application asynchronous
messaging between applications
you can use pops up that's built in and
you can plot the specific implementation
underneath of that
so if you want to do like a fanouts
pattern or a fan in
uh super easy to do that and there's a
exact
at least once delivery semantics so you
don't have to worry about
kind of events being lost uh resource
binding is kind of
one of those bindings that one of those
building blocks that allows us to extend
the functionality of dapper
consistently so there think of those as
a connector to the
uh to the outside world to other
resources that are not inside of your
runtime
you can trigger your code based on
external events when they
when they run when they kind of happen
outside of your cluster or outside of
your environment
and you can send data from your
application to outside resources
actors and i'll go through each one of
those a little deeper but trying to
provide a little summary here actors
very much like an independent unit of
distributed state and single threaded
compute capability
so if you're thinking of something that
is going to require high density
that's a great great kind of category
for that there are some
concerns you have to be aware of around
a single thread
thready threading architecture but we'll
talk about in a second
and observability it very much all about
automatic
uh kind of insight into what your
application is doing so capturing the
call graph of
of all the invocation across graph
across dapper
and the telemetry with regards to those
metrics that
are related to how the applications are
responding how many times
how long did it take and in tracing of
the
invocations across multiple services if
you're talking about microservices
you probably have a call stock that
involves four or five
ten put even more microservices and
being able to look at them
as a unit helps you kind of debug those
issues and understand the bottlenecks
and we have uh secrets we've all heard
about uh you know
these leaking all the time what dapper
is trying to do is give you a very much
opaque
get api to the secret management that
could be backed up by very robust set of
secret management solution slow
hashicorp vault
uh google kms and many other ones and
each one of those building blocks has n
number of implementations underneath
them
which means that you can choose the kind
of optimal use case per
service or per application and of what
you want to use to be
implementing these build these building
blocks
so let's kind of talk about the
architecture so uh
regardless if you run on kubernetes bar
metal vm dupper uses this
notion of a sidecar and yes i know it's
okay
sidecar is kind of correlated often with
kubernetes
but in this case dapper uses this
sidecar
approach regardless where you're running
the
the up call uh the app calls into the
upper side car
uh and dapper kind of execute uh the
functionality on behalf of your
application
this helps lower the utilization or and
offload io
often in some cases can actually improve
the performance of your application
all services invocations are encrypted
over mtls with automatic
certificate rotation including
situations where you up
upgrading the actual dapper itself
and with this release that we announced
earlier today we also added a
spf identity for service invocation and
granule access controls including all
policies if you if you like regal
yes there's overlap with many mesh
meshes out there
as you probably have already realized if
you are uh
if you really really are uh committed to
using ec or linker d
you can just disable the mtls and use
dapper in in kind of conjunction with
those
with those meshes so
how do i get one of those magical side
cards that does everything regardless
where i run well
if you're running on kubernetes that's
as simple as decorating a deployment
with hue annotations and i bought
that text over here there's many of
those annotations you can add but really
only two are required you say enable
adopter and then you also tell me tell
doctor what is the id
by which you want this application to be
used which comes into servicing location
and many other things
dapper will automatically inject a
sidecar
into the pod so it will look very much
like the
experience that you had when you were
developing using dapper on a local
machine it would
in fact your application will know
anything different
in a standalone mode if you're running
outside of kubernetes or running on any
other infrastructure you can run it
using the dapper run command in a
self-hosted mode as we refer to it
uses dapper run and regardless of what
the process is i've demonstrated three
or four in here
it could be uh directly into runtimes so
go or
node or net or whatever they might be or
it could be actually an executable
that's already
kind of compiled into machine code or
something like that it's a lot of
flexibility there
with regards to kind of dapper on
kubernetes i think this is a good one to
go a little deeper given
cncf and kubernetes uh we try to keep
dapper as light as possible so there's
really only two crds
there's four system codes although we
can we can bring it down to about two if
if you're some uh not using some of the
features so
the first one is the sidecar injector
this is what checks for the annotations
and inject the sidecar into your pod
century generates certificates for the
sidecar implements rotation strategy
the operator tracks deployments and
deals with things like
resource discovery and component
registry
and actor placement deals with
identifying or finding where the dappers
are located
the actors are located and then uh kind
of providing metadata around us more
about actors in a minute
uh because they can be rehydrated or all
over the place depending on
where the upper so optimal deployments
for those
there's also health apis and live probes
that you would normally see in any kind
of kubernetes deployment
so let's go into those building blocks a
little deeper and kind of show them in a
real
world like examples so starting with the
key value state management
it is distributed object store for your
applications what that means
is that it outlives the session of the
application if your application goes out
of scope
it can be restarted somewhere else and
will have access to the same
content same state it has a
concurrency configuration options for
each operation so you can do first or
last wins if you're
looking around have concerns around
concurrency
has similar configuration for
consistency with regards to whether it's
a strong or optimistic
uh consistency and it's configurable
retry policy which means
it's super granule it's not only on the
entire service but it's an operation
it can be invoked per retry per
operation it's configurable
we also support bulk and transactional
operations for situations where you want
to
uh save a number of records uh or if you
uh trying to retrieve an a number of
records
the backstage for those is totally to
you up to you
there's dapper supports i think check
this morning about 12 of those
so etcd redis cassandra gcp
cloud firestore aws dynamo there's
n number of those configurations and
depending on what you prefer in the
environment you might use those
but the api which will be exposed to you
to use the state union application is
consistent
so how do you configure that for you
will see this throughout so
uh some um kind of highlights here
we're using this notion of the
components components uh are in
representations of n number of
components can be implementing a
particular building block
in this case we see uh it's a component
i call this corporate db but it could be
frankly anything
it's a component of a type of state and
in this case it's a mongodb
so dapper provides these configuration
options for any
number of those components that we've
highlighted before 70 or some before
what it gives you access to is some
metadata that you can use to configure
the actual service itself
um including like you know the database
and other things
but once configured one registry in
dapper now is becoming available
in your um in your dapper api so you can
post to it
by identifying the specific
component and save the data to a
particular collection in
in this case to [ __ ] database the
metadata is
unique to a specific store so in this
case this [ __ ] might have metadata
that's
specific to [ __ ] if you were using xcd
there might be additional parameters
there
and you will see the other options we
provided
moving on to service discovery and
invocation
so dapper like i said is a reverse proxy
for you in vocation but
that allows you to kind of locate the
services and invoke them
using the assign id so in the previous
example we used
i don't forget what we use but if you
say for example my service is the id of
your application
you can start invoking from all you
other services
within your application and and dapper
will make sure you find the right
right instance the uh all of that is
dynamic there is no configuration for
this one because the
as you kind of start the services within
dapper they all automatically are
registered and the registry is managed
for you
it works in kubernetes it works even
across name spaces so
you can cross the boundary of the
namespaces and
you can invoke them over http or grpc so
regardless what your application is
running on in this
example we have a http application that
it's calling into the grpc application
the api is consistent for that
application dapper does the protocol
translation
so grpc to http or http or grpc all of
that is done behind the scene europe
applications don't have to be aware of
what the target is
using like i said before invocations are
automatically retried on a call level
which is more granule with mo
which with what you get normally from
the meshes
uh all traffic between apps is over and
tls the automatic
it's automatic so there's zero downtime
even during the third
rotation process and um and upgrades
and because now dapper also support
provides the x
509 certificates we can do
spiffy identity across clusters
for service implications so if you for
example have one instance of dapper
running on gcp
and another one on aws you can reliably
and securely
kind of connect them and invoke each
other doctor also have
options for policy through annotations
which kind of
obfuscates a lot of the complexity as
well as for a proper upper
oppa implementation for rego so if you
prefer you writing your applications in
rego
sorry policies in regal you can you can
do that
all that comes with automatic telemetry
you don't have to create spams
uh us because dapper has the awareness
of how your applications are invoking
each other
that that parent trace id is
automatically injected
and you can start kind of seeing the
benefits i'm going to show you this
during the demo
uh later on another
building popular building block is pops
up it it really allows microservices to
communicate with each other
so publishers the publisher has no
knowledge of what the consumer is and
consumers no idea
who published the data and dapper uses
cncf cloud events to as a kind of
envelope for those so wraps all those
events for you
it provides kind of at least once
consistency sorry provides at least one
guarantees for your uh for your
publishers
so some of the common implementations
for uh pops up inside of dapper
for open source would be like redis nuts
kafka rabbitmq hazelcast
there's probably a missing bunch of
other ones and for cloud search
providers for azure it's like a service
bus or event hub
for gcp is pub sub and for aws sqs and
there's a couple other ones for each one
of those
but whichever you want to use dapper
provides you ability to scope those so
your
applications can be limited to which
topics for example which comp
applications can use each one of those
components
again very much like we've seen before
with
a state exactly same component but this
time instead of state we save pops up in
this case i'm using redis
this is inside of the cluster so we're
calling into a redis namespace
fully qualified name and we the other
thing you're going to see here i'm going
to talk a little more about secrets but
you actually see that it didn't include
the password
for red is a reference a password we'll
talk about how dapper kind of allows you
to do it
both programmatically and inside of
configuration
but once once registering inside of
dapper you get ability to
share uh post to these topics and
consumers can kind of
subscribe to them there's two different
ways to
subscribe to uh create subscriptions
inside of dapper
you can do this programmatically where
dapper queries your app
for well-known endpoint and of for
subscription
and this is kind of good for dynamic use
cases where you want to kind of respond
with a specific
configuration and the app responds with
a array of number of different
subscriptions where you tell us
to which component and topic you want to
subscribe and what is the url you want
us to send
uh you want dapper to send the data to
um that's great if you have awareness of
dapper when you are writing this
application
for situations where you already have
applications that they're aware of cloud
events or
are expecting cloud events you can use
declarative manner which dapper provides
a crd for
that allows you to subscribe to to
create subscriptions uh program through
configuration
so your application actually has zero
awareness of dapper it just says i i
know cloud events give me cloud events
and apple will send those uh to your
application
um bindings like i said it's
kind of a way to extend the
functionality of dapper uh
and and there's so many of these out
there i'm just gonna list a few and i
feel like i'm highlighting a couple of
these consistently but i'm trying to
create some variety we have two
different flavors of binding there's
input
and output bindings and the output
binding can do bi-directional
and i'll explain what that means for
input you can uh
you can think of those as triggers so
something will come from outside and
trigger your code and bring some data or
maybe not
and so kafka and all the data the kind
of
eventing service systems out there are
all
are good use of kind of binding but we
can also have apis like twilio or
twitter
and so forth it really removes a lot of
the complexity of your application
having have to have the drivers
or or sdks inside of your code and
polling for that
basically application says i don't i
don't know how this was configured but
give me your
that event and i will do something with
that it uh
your application can be in grpc or http
it doesn't matter that event can be
bound to you
and switching between these bindings and
runtime
is really as easy as changing
configuration and and in some cases
relaunching the application
so the upper hand handles a lot of the
retries and failure recovery for you
and again none of that you have to write
your application it kind of keeps your
code very lean and allows you to change
your mind post deployment
similarly in the output binding it
allows you to kind of invoke
from your code to the outside world just
like with the other ones we
have a number of these out there for
different systems and services
in fact i just saw a couple days ago
somebody just
pr a ios notification binding so you can
send events directly into your into your
phone if you're using ios
just like with input binding your your
code is free of sdks
you can switch easily switch between
bindings at runtime through
configuration
and all the retrieves are handled for
you
so regardless if you're using input and
bound point
output binding approach the
configuration of that using component is
exactly the same and at this point
you've seen me show three different
yamas that really
differ very differently very little they
only have some
metadata that's specific to in this case
for example kafka
that differs and provides you ability to
configure
but the actual notion of configuring
your bindings inside of dapper is super
consistent and easy regardless if you're
running kubernetes or if you're running
on-prem
that same file will work so in this case
we have a kafka binding
that defines a specific topic
it could be n number of those for
simplicity of demo just have one
to which it's going to be used to on the
input and for
output we also have limit which topic
can be used to
send data out of your application we
support consumer group there's a number
of other variables that kafka provides
but that kind of is the extent of that
and then
for input your application would in this
case the name of the component is my
kafka your application the route in your
application would just have to expect to
have
a there should be a route in your
application called mykafka and dapper
will post to the put
to that you also check before
for options on that just to make sure
that you actually have the route so it
doesn't start flooding you with data
before you
are ready for that and uh for
calling outside of your code into the
outside world you're just using the
consistent binding api
with that same component and and the
upper maps all of that for you
we talked uh we touched on secrets a
little before but
secrets are generally hard problems and
we've all
heard about leakage credentials out
there doppler provides you with this api
that that is consistent regardless of
which backend you use so i have
logos for four or five four of those out
there there's other options too
um but these cert the
systems are backing dappers api behind
the scene so you can manage the rotation
strategy and all that over there
and then dapper gives you this
consistent api that you can use
both from um within your code
through the same api so get for example
my secret it will return the secret
but you can also use this inside of
configuration and i'll talk about this
in a second
so in this case we're using a hashicorp
vault secret store we've configured
those with
a few configuration options there's a
number of these again
i'm just showing a few uh but you can
now invoke that api
in dapper for secrets for specific
password and you will get that value of
that
but you can also use this inside of the
configuration so what doppler will do in
this case
you will substitute these secrets uh
kind of inline those secrets for you so
your configuration is free of secrets
you can check it into repository
and as you deploy to different
environments your entire solution is
configurable at around time
and observability is
kind of a built-in building block
there's there's some configuration for
it but what there's a lot of automatic
things that happen
so i want to talk about a few of those
first of all there's a ton of
metrics that dapper gives you kind of a
visibility into with regards to the
the measure values and the counts around
time series
monitors behavior of itself of that
sidecar as well as of your application
and by default uses prometheus and
grafana there is number of options to
switch into csp specific
options like for example monitor on
azure similarly with distributed tracing
it
it profiles and monitors the upper
system services
and the application it's important for
microservices because really if you
don't have distributed tracing you don't
know how things kind of work together
um so i hope you identify bottlenecks
helps you identify some issues and
failures
and and because this um it's kind of
like a mesh like
architecture it gives you these
distributed traces automatically across
the entire stack
so servicing location or or bindings or
or
um state or any whatever that may be you
get those traces automatically and i'll
show you later
but all of that is by default available
in zipkin if you're deploying some kind
of open source centric solution
in a csp environment you can use
additional like application insights on
azure for example
and similarly with logs you get fluency
and elastic and kibana
you can substitute some of those things
and ship you
logs uh somewhere else dapper injects
bunch of metadata into your logs so you
get like
the type and the host name and component
name and app id
addresses and a bunch of other things
that give you kind of more context for
actually what happened there
right now actors as a building block
it's like i said it's an object-oriented
programming model like akka
and orleans uh provides durable
framework for hosting your
your actors that are basically what its
functionality here is
it's a self-contained unit of code that
you've delivered to dapper
that has both the state and compute and
dapper manages the
life cycle of that actor it's based for
use cases with minimal io because it's
single threaded so if you start locking
you basically like the entire solution
but there is a lot of um
benefits people can recognize through
super high density i think
the numbers have seen it's like
thousands of uh actors within a single
pod
and and obviously this can scale
horizontally and that permanence the
state of your actors offloads them when
they're not used
all of that is configurable it can
rehydrate them somewhere
else with the right state and but
because
the actual model is kind of function of
the runtime itself
dapper supports actors only in java.net
and python everything every other
building blocks up to now i told you
about is 100
across all the frameworks of the
different languages
so at this point you're saying okay this
is great but there is a lot of urls
and grpc endpoints and we have not moved
past that well
um yes we done we pro you can always use
the raw api
if you want to and in some languages
there are dynamic
it's kind of like a first-class citizen
rest apis like in node.js
it's something you're already used to
but we provide also
five sdks that we manage uh the dapper
project management is currently
there's a number of those i know there's
a ros there's c
plus and a bunch of other ones that the
community manages too
um so if one is missing that you would
like to see would love to
have you kind of contribute and help
working on that
and they give you this access to the
same api and when we go into demo in a
minute i'm going to show you
how we can leverage that to kind of
simplify the application there's also
integration into some of the frameworks
so for example functions or azure
functions
you know regardless of running on azure
aks or
another cluster you have access to uh to
those functions and
uh if you're kind of into the model of
just uh
programming only at the function unit
you can
kind of integrate it very easily into
dapper and bind
these configuration options for
different state and pops up
very easily similarly with logic apps
spring boot asp.net core and others
all right i think at this point let's go
into demo
so um what i'm going to do is
uh i'm going to start with a
actually no let's do a slight i'm going
to walk you very quickly through
the demo so we know where we are we're
going to do way over engineer
application there's probably way simpler
way to doing but to show kind of the
capability
i will um i will show the three or four
different components inside of dapper
so first of all we're going to use the
binding for twitter to
create a subscription for a specific
stream of
tweets and we're gonna combine that
within the application
and then persist each one of those
tweets into a [ __ ] database
then we're gonna add a sentiment
analysis api
as an another doppler service that's
going to be using service to service
invocation
to score each one of those tweets
sentiment so we're going to find if
they're negative positive or neutral
or mixed sometimes and when we
score those the the tweet processor will
also publish them
onto a topic and eventually we'll bring
a ui application
um that will show those tweets in a ui
don't get excited my ui
foo is super weak so it's going to be
very rudimentary application
but it will allow you kind of see how
you can subscribe to events and stream
them in this case over web sockets to
the ui
all right so let's now go to the
application so couple things i want to
show here
and obviously there's a lot of moving
parts but the first thing is we're going
to show the component for twitter
you see that even though i'm running on
a local machine i'm using secrets and
it's because
in this case i'm using a one of those
developer friendly
quick and dirty kind of secret stores
which is a file store
so in this case my secret store for
dapper is defined as a file that i'm
hosting
in my machine you can use environment
variables as well
and on a local machine allows you to
just kind of use those secrets
when later on when we move to something
like kubernetes and i should show you
how to deploy that
you will actually use the secret the
kubernetes secrets because that's the
kind of optimal use way of using there
the other thing we're going to do is
we're going to define a state in this
case i'm going to use
redis for state as well as for pops up
so that nothing changes there super easy
for your local development
and we're going to run that these other
application the other thing to kind of
point out here
is i'm actually using the dapper sdk
this is for go
the very same principle would apply for
every single other language out there i
just can't write
anything pretty much but go and even
that is pretty weak but you will see
that
um i'm creating a service the the part i
want to focus on is
the odd of creating a subscription to a
kind of binding handler is as simple as
it's a method on the client so you say i
want to subscribe to the tweets remember
we define
tweets as the component name and
and then just handle and the handler is
super simple doesn't do anything other
than
just publishing it to a to a topic
that it's configured again through
configuration
so this is as exciting as the ammo can
get let's go to
go so first what i'm going to do is i'm
going to launch
locally the viewer you will see the
dapper
went through its logging processing here
started the application
it told me that http api is on this port
and the grpc is on this port which are
configurable
and also kind of give you a nice
checkbox here you're good to go locally
and pretty much the same thing works for
every single application
what we're going to do in here we're
going to actually start a grpc
application on a specific port
this is going to be the sentiment
scoring application and we're going to
point to where the configurations are
again i'm just using go itself directly
similar i'm on a mac so mac asked me to
make sure that i allow that to happen
and and
uh exactly same thing for the tweet
processor
there are some old tweets in here and
we're going to start the tweet provider
and what's going to happen in here
is this is an http one you see the same
thing
and i use the term football and
uh for reasons that we are recording
this tweet i'm actually not going to
open the ui
because i'm embarrassed what could be
out there but i'm going to open one for
um for dapper
for term dapper that i'm actually
already running on a server
this is deployed on kubernetes and i'm
going to come back later show you how
i've done that
you will see a number of of tweets and
if you act if you're going to tweet and
please be
uh nice don't say something that will
embarrass me
and so if you tweet something it will
automatically come in here
but what for each one of those we can
see for example that i
was very excited about the spiffy
support and
oppa so i tweeted about it and the the
tweet was identified
positive joe betta actually saw that too
and jumped on it we see some people that
maybe are less
maybe they were retweeting so it's hard
to tell if they were excited about it or
not but
the sentiment is there it's kind of not
the function of that application
the one thing i want to show you is that
in the entire code there was no
mention of any tracing right our code
was very simplistic
but what we were able to do is within
your application
and actually create the map of these so
for each one of the
services we can drill down identify what
was happening we can switch to logs
we can see metrics of the entire system
in this case dapper
and and the performance characteristics
of each one of those asset changes
um so it's it's uh super
um transparent to the developer who just
writes the logic of the application they
don't have to worry about the actual
plan
are we almost out of time so i'm going
to switch quickly to this
actually let's see if somebody posted
something
okay nobody did all right oh brandon
so let's um let's go back uh
the entire demo is 100 reproducible and
it walks you through each one of those
steps you can go to this short link or
just scan the uh
the barcode um the qr code it will walk
you through the creation of the cluster
and and
if you don't have one as well as
configuring of the different components
and deploying of the application
the uh let's talk about for integration
uh very quickly or skip that even
a couple of things that the project is
doing right now with
a stable set of apis
with this new release which kind of uh
made some changes in api so at this
point the state the api is stable
we've delivered access control and
service identity like i was already
talking about
we've actually done a security audit
with one of the cncf
certified company and published those
results as part of this pr2
so you can go to github and find us uh
the reports about the security audit
that we have performed
we have also announced an
project transition to an open source
governance to a
vendor-mutual kind of way of looking at
this project making sure that this is
sustainable over time
so what's next uh
kind of by by the end of the year are we
looking to release a release candidates
of the 1.0
this is based on the feedback we've got
from customers and you people
or users using this in the real world
there's
uh we want to definitely start focusing
more on addressing the friction from the
real world use cases
so as people kind of more and more are
taking this to a to production
deployment
they feed us information and we kind of
making sure that this is the highest
priority
to make sure that this deployments are
successful um there is a fair amount of
infrastructure work going on behind the
project if you're going to be
sustainable as an open source project
you need to make sure that you have a
good performance and
performance automation we have a lot of
that too but we want to make sure that
this is all
accessible to the general community
they're going to be working on dapper
we're going to start also seating the
technical steering committee
just reaching out to the outside
community and bringing evaluating kind
of identifying who are the right people
who should be on this
and then very much kind of focusing on
ensuring the readiness for
production-grade workloads which means
paying a little more attention maybe to
the operator and make sure that some of
the
metrics that the traditional enterprise
or
large-scale deployment operator would
want to see
as the focus has been definitely on the
on the developer so far
all right in closing uh
dapper io is a good starting point for
pretty much anything on dapper
the project itself like i said is hosted
on on github so
github.com for slash docker there is a
chat on gitter
as well as twitter uh kind of monitoring
going on so
looking forward to hear you there's a
few videos about dapper
that i've kind of collected into a
playlist that you can access if you
can't find anything else
if you need me any other information i
provided my email address
which might not be the wisest thing in a
recording video but
looking forward to hear from you